the mcdonald's coffee cup case the case
where the ant
sued her nephew for hugging her these
are all examples of
the most ridiculous frivolous lawsuits
ever
or are they one of the hallmarks of the
american legal system is that if you've
been injured you have the right to have
your grievance heard in a court of law
of course one of the downsides of the
american legal system is that if you
haven't been injured
you also have the right to have your
grievance heard in a court of law but
not every newsroom or tv show has a
legal consultant on hand so they
often leave out key details and nuances
about particular cases they have a hard
time determining which ones are
which and occasionally the sensational
headlines that focus only on the dollar
amounts can sometimes give people the
wrong impression about the merits of the
case so today we're going to discuss
some of the most frivolous lawsuits that
actually
might not have been so frivolous after
all
[Music]
and of course if we're discussing
lawsuits that have been labeled as
frivolous but actually might have a
kernel of truth to them
there is no better place to start than
the ur frivolous lawsuit
that is of course the mcdonald's coffee
cup lawsuit so let's start this
discussion with the story of stella
liebeck the woman who spilled scalding
hot mcdonald's coffee on her lap
and sued the restaurant now here are the
facts as you might not have ever heard
them before
on february 27th 1992 stella liebeck
then a 79 year old woman from
albuquerque new mexico
ordered a cup of mcdonald's coffee at
the drive-through window libec was
sitting in the passenger seat of her
parked car as her grandson
stepped inside to grab some cream and
sugar since the car had no cup holders
libec placed the coffee cup between her
knees and
pulled to open the lid she then spilled
the entire cup of scalding hot coffee on
her lap
causing third-degree burns on her thighs
buttocks and groin all i remember is
trying to get out of the car
i screamed not realizing i was burned
that bad i knew i was in terrible pain
she was actually hospitalized for eight
days and underwent skin grafting
lipic was permanently disfigured after
the incident and was partially disabled
for two years
some of the trial exhibits that were
used in this particular case
shine light on just how devastating her
injuries were now of course libec sued
mcdonald's accusing the company of gross
negligence and for selling coffee that
was quote unreasonably dangerous
and defectively manufactured at trial it
was uncovered that mcdonald's had been
serving coffee between 180 and 190
degrees fahrenheit
much higher than the industry norm and
which expert testimony revealed could
cause third-degree burns in as
little as two seconds other internal
documents obtained
from mcdonald's showed that between 1982
and 1992
the company had received more than 700
reports of people being burned by their
coffee with mcdonald's having settled
claims from said injuries for more than
five hundred thousand dollars in this
case the jury awarded libec two hundred
thousand dollars in compensatory damages
but reduced that by twenty percent to
one hundred and sixty thousand dollars
to account for her own negligence in
spilling on herself the jury also
awarded her 2.7 million
dollars based on her attorney's
suggestion to penalize mcdonald's for
two days worth of coffee revenue or
about 1.35 million dollars per day the
punitive damage awards was supported by
the discovery that 700 people had been
previously burned by hot coffee
demonstrating that the company had
actual knowledge that the coffee was
being served too hot but failed to
remedy the issue the judge reduced the
punitive damages to
three times compensatory damages or 480
000 for a
total judgment of 640 thousand dollars
this decision
was appealed but the parties settled for
an undisclosed amount of probably less
than six hundred thousand dollars now if
prior to watching this video you thought
that this was a case about a clumsy
greedy woman trying to get rich quick
over her own mistake you're probably not
alone thanks to a perfect storm of
shortened news reports and outraged
political conservatives who used the
case to advocate for sharp limits on
tort lawsuits so-called
tort reform the general public was
really misinformed about the nature of
this case
she spilled hot coffee on her lap while
sitting in her car and claimed it was
too hot
every day we hear about another
outrageous lawsuit
as a result the general public wrongly
believed libec spilled coffee while she
was driving her car she was in fact just
a passenger in a parked car and that the
injuries were minor she was in fact
permanently disfigured late night
comedians and sitcoms have also heavily
parodied the case
contributing to the false image of this
particular lawsuit
you get me one coffee drinker on that
jury you won't walk out of there a rich
man
and despite what you might have heard
libec did not sue mcdonald's for
millions of dollars in fact
she didn't want to sue them at all she
originally requested only 20 000
to cover her medical bills and lost
income mcdonald's responded with
an insulting 800 settlement offer
libec's council had also
offered settlement amounts ranging from
ninety thousand to three hundred
thousand dollars but
mcdonald's also rejected all pre-trial
efforts to settle the case
i was not in it for the money i was in
it because i want them to bring the
temperature down
so that people other people will not go
through the same thing i did the most
that liebeck asked for a trial was eight
hundred thousand dollars and it was the
jury that awarded her 2.7 million
dollars which she never actually
received because the punitive damages
were
chopped and her critics claimed that
lybeck shouldn't recover anything
because she spilled coffee on herself
but
the jury did in fact find liebeck
partially responsible for her injury
applying the principles of comparative
negligence
in which liability is a portion based on
how much at fault each party was for the
injury the jury found that liebeck was
20
at fault for her injury and her
compensatory damages were reduced by
20 the amount that she was at fault but
in the past decade the libec case has
received renewed attention in the form
of the 2011 documentary hot coffee
and a 2013 retro report video from the
new york times but the false perception
about this case continues to this very
day
that stella liebeck needed to defend her
reputation
is the saddest piece of this whole story
but now what do you think completely
frivolous or is there some merit to it
let's move on to the next case about
the famous man who was trapped in a
phone booth and hit by a drunk driver
but sues
the phone company as you might recall
the 1980s were a unique period
in our history when people wore
parachute pants and mtv actually played
music that was also when the tort reform
movement which claimed america was under
assault by unscrupulous lawyers bringing
frivolous lawsuits
first began to pick up steen and fewer
is instrumental in cementing this image
of out-of-control lawsuits into the
american consciousness than
president ronald reagan but more on that
in a moment because in 1974
charles bigby following a night shift as
a custodian in the city of los angeles
used a public telephone booth to call
his girlfriend as the two spoke
bigby saw a car driving erratically
towards him but while bystanders and a
man in a
neighboring phone booth were able to get
out of the way bigby's phone booth
jammed trapping him inside
for the near fatal collusion and this is
how president reagan described that case
in a speech to the american tort reform
association
it's no surprise that the injured man
sued but you might be startled to
hear whom he sued the telephone company
and associated firms that's right
reagan claimed that this loony case was
an example of a broken tort system
sounds pretty bad
right well it might surprise you to know
that reagan left out a few key details
about this case which would not be the
first time
a few months ago i told the american
people i did not trade arms for hostages
my heart and my best intentions still
tell me that's true
but the facts and the evidence tell me
it is not
so here's what president reagan actually
left out first two years prior
a driver had destroyed a phone booth
that had been placed in the identical
spot now the phone company replaced the
booth but
didn't include a guardrail or a warning
and the replacement phone booth had a
malfunctioning door accordingly
the phone company was on notice that the
placement of the phone booth might be
dangerous
and didn't take what most would consider
reasonable measures to remedy the risk
and contrary to reagan's implication
bigby did not merely sue the phone
company bigby sued everyone he felt had
contributed to his accident including
the alleged drunk driver
as well as the horse racing track he
believed served the alcohol to the
driver and this is
typical of lawsuits where you name all
the parties that you believe are
responsible
and let the facts take the jury where
they will and the jury can apportion
faults among all of the different
defendants and finally
reagan left out just how badly bigby was
injured bigby had to have his right leg
amputated four inches above the knee and
while his left leg required skin grafts
to be saved bigby would eventually
require an artificial leg a wheelchair
and a knee brace for his left leg and
because insurance would not cover
everything bigby's unpaid medical bills
amounted to more than fifteen hundred
dollars
twenty percent of his yearly janitor
salary of seventy three hundred big
was physically unable to work and became
severely depressed and was hounded by
collections agents but in the end
frivolous or not
bigby settled for a mere twenty five
thousand 000 with the
alleged drunk driver paying half and the
racetrack vendors paying the other half
but since this is american we love our
cars almost as much as we love our guns
let's talk about the supposedly
frivolous case of the man who won 1.25
million dollars after stealing his own
car
this is a case that you just read the
headlines and it seems completely insane
man steals his own car and wins
1.25 million dollars well reading below
the headline reveals a harrowing story
of discrimination
and police brutality in 2015 dr lawrence
crosby then a 25 year old engineering
doctoral student
was fixing a loose molding on his car a
woman witnessed crosby who was wearing a
hooded sweatshirt at the time
fixing his car and assumed that he was
trying to steal the car she proceeded to
follow him
in her car from his home to the
university before she called the police
report that she saw a black man in a
hoodie steal a car
in the arrest video crosby can be heard
telling the police that he was trying to
fix his own car the police dash cam
video shows crosby getting out of his
car with both hands up holding a cell
phone in one hand
officers approached crosby with their
guns drawn police then ordered crosby to
get down on the ground and when he did
not immediately comply a group of
officers rushed crosby and threw him to
the ground
crosby said that the officers piled on
top of him proceeded to hit and knee him
and as an officer screamed to stop
resisting crosby who had his own dashcam
video can be heard saying
i'm cooperating sir you're on video
that's an fyi
officers quickly learned that crosby
owned the car and was in good standing
and even though crosby had not actually
stolen a car that belonged to him crosby
was still arrested and charged with
disobeying officers
and resisting police to repeat even
though crosby was cleared by the police
for stealing his own car
the police still arrested him for
resisting an arrest for a crime that he
in fact did not commit
a judge later threw out the charges and
the following year crosby filed a civil
lawsuit against the city of evanston
illinois
citing false arrest and excessive force
in the suit crosby demanded that the
city
and the arresting officers pay at least
50 thousand dollars for compensatory
imputative damages fees costs and such
other relief
in january 2019 the city council voted
eight to zero to settle with now
dr crosby for 1.2 million dollars after
the settlement dr crosby stated that he
was working on mending his reputation
having found himself often defending his
actions and explaining what happened
that night
once the case became a national headline
and it makes sense if you just read the
headlines one could have gotten the
wrong idea about what happened but
moving forward dr crosby said that his
first steps post-settlement
would be holding an implicit bias forum
for students and faculty at stanford
university where he earned his
undergraduate degree
okay fine you've probably heard about
police brutality before so that one
might not be
that surprising but have you heard the
one about the ant who sues her 12 year
old nephew for 127 thousand dollars
because he hugged her well there's an
old saying that when it comes to family
blood is thicker than water but in the
rough and tumble world of litigation
it's not that uncommon for grieved
relatives to sue one another for
personal injury but what
is uncommon is when the plaintiff is an
adult suing a very small
child and so goes the story of jennifer
connell the woman dubbed the ant from
hell
who sued her nephew for 127 thousand
dollars over a birthday hug gone wrong
you probably heard some of the facts of
this case when the story first went
viral
in 2011 an upper east side ant attended
a birthday party for her then
eight-year-old nephew shawn the
precocious lad was riding around on his
brand new bicycle his first two-wheeler
when he saw his beloved aunt and when he
spotted her sean who was technically the
son of a cousin but refers to connell as
his aunt
dropped his new bike on the ground and
ran to his aunt at full speed
he leapt into her arms exclaiming auntie
jen
i love you auntie jen was caught off
guard by the leaping nephew causing her
to fall and break her wrist
two years later she sued young sean for
127 thousand dollars now if this sounds
ridiculous
you would not be alone in thinking so
when word of the case broke out people
blasted the ant who was a human
resources manager
on social media dubbing her the ant from
hell and the
worst and ever and antichrist and the
news media also piled on portraying her
as a greedy money grubber bringing an
inherently ridiculous case against a
child
the trial didn't help her image auntie
jen testified that her injury harmed her
social life by making her unable to hold
the plate of hordurbs she further
testified
quote i live in manhattan in a third
floor walk-up so it's been very
difficult and we all know how crowded it
is in manhattan
she argued that young shawn had been
negligent when he jumped into her arms
and broke her wrist and therefore that
she was entitled to 127 thousand dollars
as compensation for her medical bills
now the jury disagreed deciding that she
deserved zero compensation after a mere
20 minutes of deliberation now this
seems like a textbook case of
overzealous litigation well here's the
rub and
hold on because it involves both legal
nuance and
insurance law i know everyone keeps
asking for more insurance law and
extremely nuanced legal points so
uh you know here you go under
connecticut law she literally had no
choice auntie jen first submitted her
claim to the homeowner's liability
insurer of sean's parents
in response the insurer offered her a
mere one dollar settlement offer and
when auntie jen wanted to litigate her
damages claim
her attorneys informed her of an
inconvenient fact about connecticut law
it's illegal to name a homeowner's
insurance policy as a defendant in a
personal injury case
the only way she could get a homeowner's
insurance policy to pay her medical
bills
was to get a judgment against the person
who injured her so
regardless of how silly it might have
appeared to outside observers auntie jen
was required as a matter of law
to sue the party that she thought
injured her which in this case
means suing a young child auntie jen did
not win her case but just because a
party loses a lawsuit doesn't mean that
it was filed without any legal basis a
minor can be held liable for injuring
another under connecticut law in 1960
the connecticut supreme court had
held that a 17 year old girl could be
held liable to her minor siblings
arising out of her negligence in a car
accident and in outlining the legal
standard of care for minors who injure
third parties
the connecticut supreme court wrote a
minor is liable for injuries negligently
inflicted by him
upon another it is true that in
determining the negligence of a minor
the law applies to him a standard of
conduct which will vary according to his
age judgment and experience
but the law does not grant him a
complete immunity from liability for his
torts
even in negligence so this lowered
standard of care for miners is
consistent with what happened in auntie
jen's case
at trial the judge instructed the jury
that had sean been 18 at the time of the
incident
he probably would have been expected to
act like a reasonable adult however
because the boy was only eight years old
at the time
the jury had to consider only what a
prudent eight-year-old boy would have
done and on that basis the jury held
that young sean was not liable for any
damages after the case miss connell
appeared on the today show with her then
12 year old nephew to clear the air she
explained that
her relationship remained sound and she
deeply regretted that connecticut law
forced her to take this route
i was informed that we had sean had to
be named i was never comfortable with
that
as for young sean he stands by his aunt
sean what do you want people to know
about your aunt that i love that i love
her
and she loves me either way this will
probably make for some awkward family
reunions in the future
but you can tell that sometimes what you
see in the news can be misleading or it
might just be
half of the story but not with today's
sponsor morningbrew
i've actually been subscribed to
morningbrew for forever it's one of my
absolute favorite newsletters and it's
awesome that they wanted to sponsor this
channel morningbrew if you didn't know
is a free daily newsletter delivered
monday through sunday it gets you up to
speed on business finance tech and law
in
just five minutes and it provides a
fantastic quick survey of the most
important issues while being witty
irreverent
and informative and did i mention it's
completely free
it tells me how much my stocks are going
up and how much everyone else's crypto
is going down
yesterday for example i learned about
all the crazy stuff going on with the
britney spears conservatorship
that high schoolers have a right to cuss
outside of school according to the
supreme court
and that the chinese government is
shutting down the only free newspaper in
hong kong it's basically exactly the mix
of news that i'm actually interested in
and it's one of the few emails that i
actually open so legal eagles this one
is a complete
no-brainer morning brew is completely
free and it takes less than 15 seconds
to subscribe
just click on the link in the
description to get morning brew for free
and not only will you get a newsletter
that you will actually read
but you'll actually help out this
channel too so click on the link in the
description to get morningbrew right
away
so do you agree with my analysis leave
your objections in the comments and let
me know if there are some other lawsuits
that are frivolous or
seem frivolous but aren't and check out
this playlist over here with all of my
other legal reactions including a whole
video about
lawsuits that really are frivolous so
click on this playlist or i'll see you
in court